your welcome home shows I heard we're
legendary
yeah it was turned the [__] up oh three
Greedo man you could say whatever you
want man
um welcome home man appreciate you it's
good to see you uh you know I mean I
feel like while you've been incarcerated
I brought your name up so much in so
many interviews because I feel like you
don't get enough respect when it comes
to just your influence
you know I feel like you and Draco had
that in common in terms of just like
just the influence on like a whole
entire generation of what we what we
consider hip-hop you know what I'm
saying just whether it's La [__] or not
man so it's good to see you man welcome
yeah yeah we just on some update in
relationship like let's
we understand what the original culture
was and it still is for some people of
those ages or wherever they from but
we're like bro we got Detroit Partners
in Atlanta partners and New York
Partners and Memphis Partners like it's
really like the whole world is on their
fashion [__] now it's not like when like
you're looking certain states that have
Big T's and Thursdays like everybody's
wearing Balenciaga and [__] and they've
been doing that [__] in L.A we want to
speak for that we want to speak for the
flockers we want to speak for like the
other pieces of the culture from here
whether we was doing it or not was not
what we was trying to put we were just
putting a soundtrack to people who had
to do that to get how they live the
flockers the Trappers just the whole
line just it was just all three of us I
was gonna say Shoreline too yeah
Shoreline had a lot a lot of influence
as well so I got to give them props
because I feel like it was kind of at
the same time y'all all kind of getting
it yeah that was our family drummer
seeing Mafia drummers stinky beaches
that was our family Draco called us in
um
yeah that's how it was though and we was
all just on something like this a new
wave
even though Jeezy like [__] oh Jeezy
showed a new culture I feel like for
Hispanics from Los Angeles even though
there is a lot of new artists that
suspending that's hard too I'm just
saying at the time
people didn't know like there was people
that was living like he was living or
dressing like that's what I tell oh
Jeezy I'm like you kind of cause I'm
from Arizona so I'm very well aware of
like Chicano rap and a lot like a lot of
the Mexican rap history I'm like oh
Jeezy you kind of show people like you
don't have to make that like
stereotypical not even just that that
was like really who he was like for sure
for sure uh he was really like we didn't
dress him in what he was dressed in you
know what I'm saying he was coming with
them CDG Air Forces and shooting right
spilling lean all over them or just the
way that he was doing [__] was like damn
this [__] is hella creative so I really
um took it like an old Jeezy early
do you remember how old you were or how
old Jeezy was when you guys initially
met because oh no he was a baby all them
[__] babies I'm the big bro you know
right you're the big homie yeah all them
[__] babies y'all talk to someone the
other day and he told me how old he was
turning I don't know if he told anybody
yeah I'm like never what the [__] like
you're only that old you're my little
kid you know what I'm saying so I'm like
oh [__] but um I had personal time with
every member of uh Shoreline
I can't say every member's thinking
because it's a million but a lot of uh
me and Ralphie probably have more songs
from back then than me and Draco doing
we got a lot of songs shout out to
Ralphie who's just up here even with
catchy the great like that was one of my
co-stars and he was stink team so
um
that was just a fun ass time it was
heartbreaking so much stuff that came
behind it
because it was like Archer broke up when
we didn't even break up you know what
I'm saying it was just like
you go you go away you gotta go sit down
obviously Shoreline kind of goes their
separate ways you know rest in peace to
Draco rest in peace to catchy it just
like you said Long Live you know what
I'm saying we right we we going on
whatever we ain't we ain't getting no
rest alone live how's it safe for you
you being locked you being locked up
when Draco passes that had to be a hard
thing to deal with from you know Behind
Bars yeah I ain't really rock with the
phone for a while after that you know
what I'm saying I didn't really
um just know my background and the type
of individuals I come up around like I
know that nobody got no filter and I
didn't really want to hear it uh
no opinions or anything more than what I
was already hearing because the stories
was sounding crazy
and
just wrapping them out
mind around everything because I had
just
lost off I think that was just a few
weeks before yeah dog passed away in
November uh and then Draco passed away
in December and it's different when it's
people that you don't spend time with
her shook hands with her Wildwood or
anything you know what I'm saying or
um yeah Dolph was a close friend of mine
Dolph was a great guy the last
what I woke up in a mansion
where I was with a lil pump and Uzi and
smoke purp and dub and we was in there
and we was recording and chilling and
[__] and I missed my flight to go to
Texas so I caught the first one in the
morning and the last people that I
talked to on the phone
was nipsy and off or getting on the
plane before you turn yourself in yeah
so it was just like crazy you know like
uh the people that were
rooting for me or you know whatever uh
collaborate with me or whatever the case
is whatever our relationship was it was
just crazy to
just somebody that you used to just
shake hands with okay out of all the
bunch this is what's going on and then
it started to feel like back to back
with pnb rock Chris Rock yeah and let
alone like homies from my ghetto um
there were just so many
thanks back to backer childhood friends
or just family members off code so I was
just like you know when the Draco [__]
came it was towards the end
as well as the takeoff and pnb rock and
it was just like you know I'm just
moving my phone away man oh yeah you
know what I'm saying just
if it wasn't taking care of business I
wasn't really getting on the phone right
I can't blame you man
what was uh the the conversation with
nip and Dolph like before you turn
yourself in
nip first thing was just like um
don't worry about it
because even though you gonna be gone
you left such an impact on the city
it's gonna go it's gonna keep going
everybody love you Greedo like you know
what I'm saying I'm calling you as a
brother you know what I'm saying just
you know giving me that pep talk before
I went out to the ring you know what I'm
saying just
that always was you know the coach you
know I'm saying that always was
I mean we did a few songs we did some
songs but our relationship was just kind
of like just
Oh no just like yeah [__] like he was
so excited for me he would call me when
I go to New York for the first time or
go to double XL or wherever I'm going
and he'd just be like yeah [__] yeah
just this is just this is this yeah this
is what you're supposed to be doing and
just like I'll be telling people like
when I saw Kobe funeral and Jordan was
talking about when Kobe hit him any time
of the night hey should I shoot like
this should I do like that that's who
Nipsey was for me like most rappers we
operate like in the wee hours in the
night anyway but
um just that pep talk and the same with
Dolph just the same old
you know what I'm saying you good you
gonna bounce back
Dolph was a great guy man Nipsey of
course